tagli a tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a
questo nuovo video sono bravi j
ed oggi siamo tornati su un video che
farà calare la mia autostima di parecchi
punti all'incirca un annetto fa vi ho
fatto un video reaction sui miei video
da bambino e da un anno che mi chiedete
di fare secondo episodio di reaction
video vecchie e daje è stata abbastanza
ridicolo al tempo fare quel video di
prove sono io quello che sto facendo a
sto giocare una gnocca è ciò che ha già
capito tutto della vita panico e basta
fare due minchiate e la [ __ ] arriva
grande così non ti preoccupare che da
grande non succederà mai
forse perché sta alla gnocca adesso
cambiano i tempi caro mio
guardali guardalinee che schiavista la
tv ha già capito tutto ha già capito che
essendo donna può farmi fare quello che
vuole già vista portando via mi sto
magna la palla una palla a cielo la tipa
ha beccato il babbo
[Musica]
mazza che voglia di vivere ora va che
voglia di mangiare che ciò non vedevo
l'ora del magnasco piatto della bomba ma
lei come me piace oddio passo falso
picchia gatto perché sto picchiando un
gatto ragazzi tutto per cosa fai lo re
allora e allora addio addio è pazzo
pazzo sto bambino fa sta facendo io non
farei mai una cosa del genere ha messo
ragazzi avere troppa paura che il gatto
milli graffi
come mostra certi madonna è una sfida
all'ultimo sangue che ti ha fatto altro
gatto e pomona tina bella libero di
titoli perché fai con il solo di nonna a
caso mica sei un mago aracne scappa
fantastici che in gara i gendarmi che
cosa ha detto mia mondo qualcuno che
capisce il pugliese per favore mi
traduca questa cosa che sta dicendo mia
nonna
c'è un motivo se io da piccolo capivo un
terzo delle cose che mia nonna mi diceva
c'è un motivo
una recita eccolo la prof cos'è e se
stanno al limone weasley e ragazzi da
piccola ero tipo con giovanni se tutti
mi stavano tutti mi parlavano le tipe mi
stavano dietro quello che cazzo è
successo nel tempo perché è scomparso
tutto o questo ragazzino meno uno dei
momenti più belli della vita me lo
ricordo ancora veli grido preparata che
quando io ero piccolo non so anche
adesso in realtà quando mi cantano la
canzoncina nei tanti acume perché non
sono mai che cazzo fa in quei momenti
poco soli e vabbè siccome io sono timido
col tempo ho imparato a fare sto sorriso
da ebete e arrossire quando mi cantano
la canzoncina quando ero piccolo che non
avevo imparato questa tattica
incredibile ed è il momento in cui mi
cantavano tanti auguri succedeva questo
[Applauso]
bianchi è proprio bella questo brano the
mirror ottimi vino un cazzo zio o la mia
bici alle 13 oddio ma ricordavo più
successo a palla
ap alla bella zio aspetto recita di
natale del 2006 orco dio
ecco le eco il singolo applauso cosa fa
l'occhiolino a casini ma perché applauso
non hanno fatto niente
eccolo lì dietro a tutti quanti che va
fatta in mezzo a due avevo che stava
rimorchiando mi scusi grazie a flat è la
tipa 6 chiazzata però io non me ne frega
niente
sono rimasto lì cosa vuole e se tale
cucina così cazzo degli importi nella
vita non riesco a sopportarli viaggi nel
tempo mi fa male proprio a prescindere
che allega mele denis è la mia migliore
amica e nella valutate se taciuto
telecamere
continuano a salutare da mezz'ora basta
che lo state facendo alla grande
ok allora sì che si in homo vero zio ma
trovando poi lombardo mucchio noti a
giove la mango succede poi andiamo
andiamo sul quale c'è un motivo se
maison rincoglionito col tempo capita la
situazione che non è proprio idilliaca
posso fare una domanda perché sono col
papillon del brevetto in paris st ce lo
sapesse non avevo fatto vedere della
befana con chi ci mancherebbe altro che
dovrebbe venire la befana nuda famme
capì zio praticamente io c'ero st fissa
che doveva farmi saltare mio padre come
per quale motivo è quello il motivo mi
divertiva questa cosa e cosa c'è di
strano o ubriaco ragazzo ho fatto un
salto ubriaco abbiamo perso l'altra
ragazzina la cosa bella che io ci avevo
la culla che era scritta cos'è in russo
bambolotto lega bambolotto il bambino di
gesù cao cao c'è stata non un periodo in
cui era carino i cavi mancano i momenti
che peccato
ciao amore ciao papà c'è una donna che
mi tocca tra bp foto l'ho fatta nella
foga mano e vi è che sia capace anche
stasera è già imparando adesso solo
terribile
ecco proprio bene nella skille meglio e
poi imparare così a star seduto ci
vogliono anni d'allenamento chi ubriaco
perenne regalate ai ragazzi fa lasciamo
perdere tutto quanto ho concluso che
l'episodio non so quanto dura non ha
idea però non posso andare avanti così
dio mio dio non so con che coraggio
metterò questa roba su internet però lo
devo fare perché ormai l'ho registrato e
[ __ ] lasciate un bel light da
piccolo non sarò caduto invano vero che
vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose il suo viso
piaciuto affatto un commento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook con i
video da tale iscrizione senza reti di
scrittrici diavolo prossimo vino e la
ragazza